Let's go next to our caller from the nine
five, four area code.
Who's calling today from nine five four
Joelle, Joelle, what's up before lardo?
Um, yeah, I'm a Andrew yanked supporter and
um, uh, I was just, I just wanted to get your
thoughts on the coming automation wave and
I know you don't, you're not a big fan of
is UBI or universal basic income, but uh,
Bernie wants, his answer for automation would
be a federal jobs guarantee.
I was wondering, what would you, uh, what
would those two options for automation, what
would you prefer if like in the future you
had to pick one?
So I'm not against UBI, I just don't see UBI
as the solution to automation.
I've been critical before when Andrew Yang
said that UBI, any dollar you get from UBI,
you lose from other benefits.
I want UBI to be additive.
The idea is to raise people's standard of
living, not to just change where they're getting
money from.
So, so I'm not against UBI.
In fact, I've been talking about UBI, including
with Andrew Yang on this program much longer
than almost any other show has.
I just don't see UBI as the deal as the way
to deal with automation.
I think that, um, there has to be some kind
of bridge solution.
There are going to be jobs automated away.
It's just the reality.
And what we have to think about is which industries
are likely to be hardest hit?
What kind of retraining can we do if people
who are going to lose jobs for moving towards
industries that are going to flourish or potentially
even grow as we continue to move forward.
And for me, it's, it's not about jobs guarantee
versus using UBI to pay people who lose jobs
to automation.
These are kind of all disjointed things.
I think we need sort of a much more holistic
approach and UBI for me is very interesting,
but not the way to deal with automation.
All right, thanks.
Thank you very much man.
I appreciate it.
All right, very good.
Thank you so much for the call.
We will go to a break and come back with more
right after this.
Sorry to everybody I was not able to pick
up on.
We always get more calls
then the number we can take, but that's a
good sign.
That's a good problem to have.
Quick break back after this,